[Musique]
paul alias p as est partagé son
quotidien de trentenaires fortune et sur
les réseaux sociaux c'est avec ces
quelques dizaines de milliers d'abonnés
sur les réseaux sociaux -les
influenceurs aurait proposé ses services
à des auto entrepreneurs pour monter de
faux dossiers de demandes de fonds de
solidarité ce garçon a été touché par le
doigt de la grave voilà et ça c'est bien
[Applaudissements]
sa méthode est astucieux gonfler le
chiffre d'affaires de 2019 pour faire
croire à un manque à gagner plus
important en 2020 puis changer de
secteur d'activité pour une profession
éligibles aux aides dans la restauration
par exemple une fois l'argent reçu le
bénéficiaire vers ce 30 à 50% de la
somme ap à cet égard de leur est si
montfaucon bien pour vivre beaucoup
10000 beaucoup plus beaucoup 15 mai
bocco mais il y dix pages à 1000 euros
par mois elle va dire que vos plus
bloquée sur le chemin beaucoup
l'afer a éclaté grâce à un livreur de
repas qui s'était fait passer pour un
chef d'entreprise il avait touché 16
milo contrôlée par le fisc il avait
évoqué paix à 7 selon nos confrères du
parisien y aurait au moins 600 57
dossiers frauduleux pour 22 millions
d'euros d'argent public détourné près de
6 millions aurait fini dans la poche de
paix à 7 chez ma mère à save dans une
maison
bale ehpad g g et l'ex femme de mon mari
c'est bon on a beaucoup de chagrin on
entretient les gens et c'est pas du jour
au lendemain alors dit pas bon on arrête
parce que un visage que vous forcément
reconnaître et qui vaut désormais tenez
vous bien 74 mille dollars pourquoi
parce que cette photo est bien il est
devenu un phénomène viral une oeuvre
d'art virtuelle un même c'est à dire une
image partager des millions de fois sur
les réseaux sociaux qui fait passer un
message
une émotion à elle toute seule ici
l'étonnement et l'inquiétude oui bonjour
audrey merci d'être avec nous oh oui
julien excusez moi c'est cette céline là
comme telles a appelé j'ai pas voulu
décrocher votre cas chaque fois 2 me par
le mal je dirais pas ça didot remercie
de me prévenir audrey celle ci alors
vous verriez comme et le progrès dit
heures monsieur courbet elle me demande
de l'argent avec des fois c'est pas vrai
dit dorothée des
ben oui mais j'ai des brushings à payer
je viens vous aimez les ach à roye
mannequin indienne c'était en 2018 elles
demandent aux coiffeurs de couper 10 cm
de cheveux à partir des pointes mais
celui ci comprend qu'il faut tout coupé
et ne laisser que disney
co coupe beaucoup trop courte que la
mannequin va très mal supporté selon
elle cette coupe raté a provoqué je cite
un traumatisme une grave dépression
porter atteinte à sa carrière et la
justice vient lui donner raison en lui
accordant 230000 euros d'indemnités
j'arrive à me rendre compte de des
moines fourchette pour donner une
fourchette beaucoup entre cinq et dix
mille
par mois ouais bah oui facile il vous
faut au moins dix mille euros par mois
oui si la facture de qu'ovide ce chiffre
encore à plusieurs centaines de
milliards d'euros le ministre des
comptes publics olivier ducept a fait le
point entre les dépenses exceptionnelles
et des pertes de recettes la pandémie a
coûté en tout entre 170 et 200 milliards
d'euros à l'état j'adore calculer le
volume d'une pyramide mais c'est très
simple forcément c'est le volume fois la
hauteur froid le périmètre est fois
l'air carré de pythagore et là on a le
résultat mais c'est évident
même pas même pas ça va sortir comme ça
samuel benchetrit a fait le calcul il ya
740 kg d'acteur dans le film c'est ce
qui m'a confirmé qu'il m'a dit il était
au combo et nous regardait quand il y
avait tous les acteurs à l'image la
première chose qui m'est venue à
l'esprit c'est chien faut que je les
paye c'est le moment de retrouver eva et
ses grosses brioche en cuisine je
souhaite poursuivre mes études en master
afin de devenir drh de société la
discipline et la rigueur sont deux
qualités que j'ai à kerry grâce à mon
parcours sportif de haut niveau en pole
dance je m'attache surtout et
encore
c'est pas mal
et est dégoûté
[Musique]
karaoké karakoé
alors là je suis en train de trouver la
tête aux crevettes c'est comme les mecs
moi j'adore le corps on coupe la tête
avec de tels propos vous risquez d'avoir
toutes les associations masculinistes
sur le dos dont il comprenait vraiment
tour un homme dudu du moyen-âge qua non
mais vous êtes fous là vous êtes folle a
vraiment sinon on peut pas dire vous
êtes folle aaa à une consoeur
journalisme mais non mais non mais parce
que vous êtes vraiment lave ou non
étaient des choses entre annoncé que
qu'est ce que j'ai à contre la loi
neuwirth limites à ne pas dépasser born
le prêtre voulait voler pardon sa
paroisse pour financer ses orgies sous
ghb ou la voilà au four et scud en
gestion ghb est ce que c'est très
différent d'une communion pendant la
messe le prêtre finit quand même par
dire ceci est mon corps
on l'a rarement vu aussi expressive il
faut dire qu'angela merkel et surprise
et doit avoir mal sur cette photo qui
fait le tour du monde à ce moment précis
la chancelière est mordu au doigt par un
perroquet est dans un parc zoologique
quelques instants plus tôt tout allait
bien mais au moment de nourrir les
animaux l'un d'eux a raté le gobelet les
petits manchots femmes appétit d'ogre
leur repas préféré du poisson prédigéré
à cet âge ils ne sont pas difficiles
et ce régime alimentaire liquide qui
fait des ravages enfin oui c'est à vous
c'est les petits crabes ces petits
crabes
[Musique]
ces craintes ont des grosses
là je reconnais bien mon fils ils
pensent à ça mais l'os pas le dire
des grossesses est pas moi je n'ose pas
dire l'adulte des grosses qui ferait
les gros
dans le ciel de canberra en australie
les drones de livraison font face à des
attaques de corbeaux comme on le voit
sur cette vidéo partagés sur les réseaux
sociaux
wing une filiale de google qui permet de
se faire livrer des petits colis par les
airs n'avait pas prévu une hostilité de
la part des oiseaux le phénomène est
telle que la société mettant pose ses
activités dans certains quartiers le
temps de trouver une solution pour que
drones et cambo cohabitent ya beaucoup
de gens qui se posent des questions sur
nous est-ce que vous avez vu à la une
alors cyril hanouna regardé c'était
votre programme avec meilleurtaux.com
comparateur de crédit et d'assurance
pour économiser